la parole est à sézanne guillon alors
commençons janvier janvier 2006 cécilia
revient place beauvau le 5 exactement le
5 pour l'ouverture des soldes
en février après s'être fait dévorer par
son chien isabelle dinoire dévoile à la
presse son nouveau visage une seule
crainte le retour d'isabelle chez elle
son chien allait-il la reconnaître
mars les bronzés dépasse le cap des 10
millions d'entrées le film pas les
migrations effrayons pas pascal sevran
c'est pas 10 millions de bits évidemment
le même mot nicolas sarkozy inaugure sa
statue au musée grévin statue grandeur
nature donc très économique en cire
si vous la placez à côté de celle de
george bush l'art est aussi
impérativement avec un cube chirac ces
trois cubes
avril la grippe aviaire frappe
l'hexagone en soutient dominique de
villepin mange du poulet le lendemain
des filets de prostituées en colère est
là aucun geste de la part du ministre
qui aurait pu s'en taper une ou deux
quand même
en soutien qu'on voit moins
une année placée sous le signe des
animaux grippe aviaire chikungunya
navarro qui perd son mulet la nouvelle
star qui plébiscitent une tortue deux
ours femelle lâché dans les pyrénées une
troisième qui retrouvent du boulot sur
le câble et bling thomas
avril 20e anniversaire de la catastrophe
de tchernobyl commémorer partout sauf en
france je vous rappelle que le nuage
toxique avait fait un détour pour nous
éviter en ukraine la spécialité locale
reste le poulet à six pattes les enfants
sont contents il ya du blanc pour tout
le monde
mais guide rue admis astier par chirac
15 mois de prison qui saute pour
services rendus dans le domaine du sport
à ce compte-là zidane beaucoup plus
titre est pour être us id sa femme butée
un flic ou égorger une petite vieille
juin au sommet de l'otan poutine cloue
le bec de dick cheney un poutine très en
forme et légèrement dégarni parec le
soir dans sa chambre d'hôtel il mettait
au point un cocktail thé vert et
polonium juillet 2006 le plus chaud
depuis 50 ans en france malheureusement
on a eu un mois d'août pourri et les
lieux ont pu récupérer
l'idéal ce serait un juillet 2006 et
tout de suite derrière un août 2003
voyez la canicule ginette et des lames
et là on ferait une vraie économie sur
nos cotisations retraite
ou te le 11 chute à vélo de richard
virenque chars qui depuis ce jour
détient la meilleure imitation de franck
ribéry
en
septembre
amélie nothomb sort son livre que nous
tous les mois de septembre la rentrée
des classes les impôts et un livre
d'amélie nothomb c'est malheureux mais
c'est comme ça
octobre véronique courjault congèle
trois bébés madonna en adopte un que
choisir s'endormir doucement la tête
posée sur un sac de poisson pané picard
ou supporter pendant 18 ans madonna les
préceptes de la kabbale
novembre ça y est le cocktail de poutine
est prêt je vous l'avais annoncé en juin
décembre s'il est élu sarkozy annonce un
ministère de l'immigration à sa tête
johnny hallyday qui donne l'exemple en
émigrant suisse ministre de la culture
steevy régulation des naissances pascal
sevran
santé contrôle des stupéfiants doc
gynéco ministre de l'intérieur jean reno
famille et cohésion du couple à sa femme
cécilia à la semaine prochaine
c'était en effet les corrections de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux